TEJ CHAJED: I'm Tej, I'm a grad
student in computer science,
and I worked with a team of
eight on a game called Snap.
All of us were course six
majors in computer science.
We created a game called
Snap, which our client,
who is from the Red Cross, he
presented us with this game
in class.
The game works where
you both come up
with words, two players
come up with words,
and whenever you
see the same word
you snap and you get a point.
So our task was to create a
digital version of this game,
both to make the
game more engaging
and also to help them
collect data on what words
people were submitting, because
it's sort of a free association
game and helps them get a
sense of what people think
about a complex topic.
So for Snap we actually
had a concrete game
that the client gave us
and we knew exactly what
project we'd be working on.
Snap is also a little
bit different in
that it's a much more technical
game, because we're not
coming up with sprites, we're
not coming up with a story.
It's quite bare bones
in terms of interface.
And so we had a much more
standard coding project
for our game.
But at the same time, there
were game design aspects
to what we had to do.
We still had to think about
how to go beyond what we played
in class and port over the
game to a digital version that
will still be engaging
and didn't rely too much
on the human interaction,
the face to face interaction.
So at first we actually
thought that our game
would be much more
restrictive, because we thought
that the clients had a lot
of existing ideas about how
the game should be played and
what works well for getting
good feedback out of people.
As we went on, we were
pleasantly surprised
to find out that we actually
had a lot more creative freedom
than we thought.
And really, they
just wanted something
that resembled the original game
and accomplish what we needed,
which was to get
people to give words
and say what they were thinking.
So that was really nice for
us to be able to really think
of what we wanted to.
At the same time
though, the client
was interested in using the game
much earlier than we expected.
The goal for all the
projects is that they
remain open and
available for people
to see over the next month.
We've actually been running the
game in the past couple weeks.
And that has also
required some effort
on our part to do exactly
what the client needs
for their specific
runs in the past week.
So traditionally,
this course does not
allow people to use
networking, because it
tends to be very buggy.
It tends to be something
that if it doesn't work,
simply makes the whole
game fall over flat.
And we decided to violate
this rule very early on.
The rules are all
suggestions, after all.
And we were confident in
our ability to do this,
partly because we had
a lot of experience
with networking, with
distributed systems.
I actually work in
And we also were experienced
with the technologies
that we were using,
which definitely helped.
I think that the learning
curve for those technologies
was a little bit
more than we could
have done in these eight weeks.
So this course is nominally
about creating video games,
but in reality, as the
instructors admitted,
it's about project management.
And I think that the course does
a really good job of teaching
you project
management by example,
by forcing you to
actually do it.
And I think that's
why it's structured
as four games as opposed
to one big game, which
is what you might expect.
And I think that that
was really useful for us
to learn project management.
Game development was
a nice side benefit,
but I don't think we learned
a lot of game design.
I think we just tried
it and mostly we
were learning, how do
you manage a project,
how do you manage
a software project?
Games are a little bit different
in that the goal is fun and not
so much coming from a client.
The last project
notwithstanding, mostly games
are about you want to
create something fun.
I think the biggest
challenge for us in Snap
was getting people engaged,
getting our team engaged
in the project.
There's a lot of other
classes that people are taking
and this is not necessarily
the highest priority
on everybody's list.
And that was something that
you really have to work around.
You really have to find ways to
get people engaged in the topic
and get people to
contribute where
they can in the number of
hours that they have available.
So I don't know how
completely successfully we
were at getting people to
contribute as many hours
as we needed, but
definitely part of it
was making sure the
tasks were very clear,
so that not everybody was
thinking about the whole game,
but instead could think
about their specific tasks
and what they need
to do on their part.
And that was part of what
the project management was,
was making sure that people
have the information they need
to do the tasks that they need
to get done without thinking
about the whole project.